This one is really tough, so don't worry if you struggled. The expression we
want is the quantity b divided by 2 squared. For this first example, our b was
equal to 6. So if we do 6 divided by 2 and square it, we would get 9. In the
second case, b was equal to 12. So, 12 divided by 2 squared would be 6 squared,
which is 36, the amount that we should add. In the third case, we had b was
negative 4. So negative 4 divided by 2 equals negative 2, and then, we square
it to get positive 4. Notice that in each case, we always added a certain
amount. This is because even if b is negative, we end up squaring this value,
so that way it turns out positive. To complete the square, we'll always add a
positive amount, no matter if the b term is negative. And this also works for
our last example. The b was negative 10, so we'll write that here, then we
divided by 2, which gives us negative 5, and we square it to get negative 25.
This is the powerful expression that we need in order to complete the square.
If you found the expression, and that's pretty amazing. Again, this is a really
hard pattern to find and generate on your own. Let's see how we can use this to
solve some quadratic equations by completing the square.